now I hear that this is the first time
that we will see the show through a
woman's eyes correct Kate Mulgrew the
brilliant came over you know she she she
set the tone with that and for me it's
it's being a first officer so it's being
being a woman but also then being a
black woman then also being first
officers yes the first time it's been
told from those three person who wasn't
a cancer so it's always the captain is
usually accented right right so she's
she's she's first officer she's she's a
scientist a brilliant mind and also an
incredible officer an incredible you
know there's the captain give the plate
the traditional captain's role well
there's nothing traditional about this
Star Trek I'm because people who'd like
to not date before you'll notice the
same show but it's made for 2017 and in
the future so it was always the case
even in the 60s that was absolutely
about the world that people were living
in and the struggles they were facing in
the streets but the prism of fantasy and
we live in complicated difficult
interesting times and those reflected in
the shed and through the captain as well
he's a complicated interesting typical
guy this takes place before the original
yes so kind of lay that out and explain
it to everybody who's watching well it's
ten years prior to - Kirk's mission and
evidence in TOS and so it's different
ship obviously you know we start off on
the Shinjo you know we also have
discovery and everything but but yeah it
is 10 years before so yeah
bass playing Spock's father CEREC James
brains placemarks mother Sarafine he's a
character who is introduced in the
original series yeah we get to meet him
a little earlier when he has a little
slightly different job and then we also
get to see his relationship with Sonique
was character who was raised on Vulcan
yeah I'm adoptive father in a sense I
take her into I think has been device to
make sure that people who've never seen
Star Trek before just enjoy the
adventure for those people who did watch
either the original series or all this
series it's got a whole bunch of other
Easter eggs and the layers of Cameron in
it so there yes but it works perfectly
well if you've ever seen anything so
they the people who are deep in this and
you know like that you were there today
will be really satisfied because they'll
be furious and they all end up doesn't
beat each other to a pulp in big Star
Trek for me because that's what we won't
be laying a trail of candy exactly
candy boy there is a tremendous amount
of protective love for this absolutely
and that's so much of what drives any
sort of skepticism is so driven by
wanting to make sure that this is gonna
be good that's what I see is a
compassionate connection to this and
wanting to make sure that it's gonna do
it just never gonna be in the front row
to watch this and be furious every week
like there's a bunch of people who are
so incensed about things they're worried
together go wrong texting themselves
against what if it doesn't then I
understand then there's lots of people
were getting very excited so it's a real
mixture yeah I feel like the show
ultimately belongs to the fans
absolutely and the way heads are kind of
gonna do our installment but they hello
there's one right off sorry somebody
we're all in this together
it's like III liken it to being a tonic
at a campfire you know we're telling the
story you're hearing the story but we're
all in it together it's one big you know
it's one big community and so we
appreciate the pension that they have we
appreciate we have the passion or
something it's the shows they made by
fans written by fans a night to find
hopefully we need it with ours